Muy buenos días, pizarritas. Soy Nayef Aguer y hoy os traigo el último Q&A de los cuatro esta temporada.
¿Qué pasa, pizarritas? Ya estamos aquí un viernes más con Mundial de Clubes, mercado de fichajes, calendario de la Liga
y por última vez en esta temporada los cuatro porque en seguida Nau coge vacaciones más que merecidas. ¿Qué tal, Adri? ¿Qué tal, Álex? ¿Qué tal, Nau? ¿Cómo estáis?
¿Qué tal, chicos? Muy buenas.
Estoy cansado, jefe.
Y además...
Oye, que Nayef Aguer siga con la camiseta de la Real Sociedad a 4 de julio.
Ha llegado un poco tarde, la verdad. Estoy de acuerdo, ha llegado tarde el tema.
Y que tenga acento madrileño. Esto ya me tiene...
Bueno...
¿Sabemos cosas?
Bueno, es un poco la RAF, ¿no?
Claro, soy castizo. Soy castizo.
Y voy a tener siempre la Real Sociedad en el corazón.
¿Qué opinas de Miguel Quintana, Nayef Aguer?
Buen peinado, mal periodista.
Normal.
Bueno, chicos, tenemos hoy material del bueno, porque hay preguntas muy pero que muy interesantes sobre Gonzalo García, Erling Brauthallan,
el calendario, Rodrigo Riquelme, los centrales de Valencia... Tenemos un variadito de verdad.
Voy a arrancar, sin más dilación, con Matthew22 que pregunta...
¿Por cuál creemos que es el techo y el suelo de Gonzalo García?
Y dentro, entiendo yo, de ese techo, nos pregunta también si creemos que podría ser el 9 de la selección.
Que bajo mi punto de vista, para esta pregunta creo que hay que ir piano piano antes de plantearnos esas cosas.
Pero en cuanto al techo y el suelo, Adri, comienzo por ti.
¿Qué dibujarías para Gonzalo García?
A ver, techo muy alto. Por lo que estamos viendo en el Mundial de Clubes diría que el techo es bastante alto.
A mí me está desconcertando bastante el rendimiento que está dando porque está siendo muy inesperado.
Es decir, Gonzalo García antes del Mundial de Clubes parece que estaba muy cerca de salir cedido,
se hablaba mucho de la opción del Getafe y creo que a todos nos encajaba, bueno, en un equipo de primera división,
mitad de tabla para que se empezase a foguear en la máxima élite.
Pero lo que está haciendo en el Mundial de Clubes creo que es importante.
No me atrevo a hablar en vista de la selección española todavía porque creo que es pronto,
pero creo que se está ganando un sitio en la plantilla del Real Madrid así que te echo muy alto del delantero.
A ver, en temporadas anteriores, por ejemplo, en la 23-24 marcó 5 goles en 27 partidos,
en esta ya es la de explosión total, esta 24-25 con el récord de goles en primera red con 25.
Obviamente es un futbolista que por condiciones te podría encajar,
pero no que pudiese llegar ahí. Tiene unas piernas muy fuertes, es un futbolista que se asocia bien,
es un futbolista que domina el área.
Yo creo que por condiciones, si la progresión que sigue es la que estamos viendo ahora,
de marcar 25 goles en primera red, hacerlo con los mayores en un momento de necesidad para el Madrid,
dar ese paso hacia adelante, yo creo que podríamos hablar de un futbolista de selección,
que igual en este próximo año no, pero probablemente para los venideros sí que pudiera estar ahí.
Es que, Naúl, hay una cosa que creo que ya hemos comentado en la radio, pero que me parece muy significativa
y es que más allá de que esto no deja de ser un mundial de clubes en un periodo de pretemporada
y más allá de que tres de los cuatro rivales son de una entidad inferior, claramente inferior al Real Madrid,
cuando hay un jugador en un Real Madrid, en un Barça, también pasa con Atleti,
que no está a la altura técnica ni te diría creativa, pega el cante muy rápido.
Este tipo de futbolista que los controles, que los pases, dices que sí que tiene cosas,
pero es que no le ves calidad Real Madrid en este caso.
Y Gonzalo García nos podrá parecer mejor o peor en según qué aspecto,
pero en ningún momento ha transmitido la sensación de ser un canterano o de ser un futbolista
que no pega con una calidad técnica altísima, porque estamos hablando de un equipo con Jude Bellingham,
con Arda Guler, con Vinicius Junior, etc.
Y esto ya es mucho decir.
Claro, el tema, se lo comentaba otro día Adrián en el programa,
me parece que se está ganando ser una especie de Nacho de la delantera,
un futbolista que combina bien con todos, que sale y cumple, se habla mucho de José Lu,
yo creo que es otra cosa, se ha comparado mucho con Raúl,
pero es ese futbolista de rol que complementa muy bien lo que ya tienes
y creo que eso es un encaje muy bueno para un futbolista que,
lo comentaba el otro día en la ronda de entrevistas que hacía David Ancelotti,
es que se tienen que dar muchas circunstancias para que tú como delantero puedas tener un hueco en el Real Madrid
y puedas explotar como lo ha hecho él.
Creo que está demostrando que merece minutos, creo que es evidente,
mejora al equipo, hace mejor a los que tiene alrededor,
que creo que es lo que tiene que hacer un futbolista en su rol y en esta aparición.
Ahora bien, hablar de suelos y techos, un chaval que lleva diez partidos con el Real Madrid,
la mayoría de ellos con ratitos residuales,
calma, calma, porque hablabas de esos futbolistas que aparecen en pretemporada y no me daban mucha atención,
no sé por qué me he ido a la famosa pretemporada aquella de Ricky Puch,
que parecía que Ricky Puch era, claro, calma, calma.
El chaval mola mucho, deja de progresar, pero falta muchísimo para empezar a pensar en que Gonzalo puede ser nueve de la selección,
y es una de las que me parece bien que ojalá, porque es uno de esos futbolistas que puede complementar muy bien lo que hay en España.
A mí lo del Nacho de la delantera me parece muy bien tirado,
porque ya sabéis que a mí Gonzalo desde la primera vez que le veo en categorías inferiores de la selección española me gusta mucho.
Le vi en banda derecha, a mí me cuentan que sobre todo jugaba en aquella época en banda izquierda
y que luego es con Álvaro Arbeloa cuando pasa a la delantera.
Y es verdad que está exhibiendo una intuición y una capacidad para imponerse en el área,
con sobre todo un gran remate de cabeza que me parece que llama mucho la atención,
pero esa movilidad, ese entendimiento del juego, esa capacidad también para trabajar y esa cuota de gol
me parece que hace muy bueno esa comparación, ese silogismo entre Nacho y Gonzalo García.
Es complicado ser el Nacho de la delantera, porque el Madrid siempre se refuerza más en ataque que en defensa
y eso te va quitando espacio, pero después de este verano del Real Madrid,
donde lo de Rodrigo tiene mala pinta en cuanto a la continuidad con el conjunto blanco,
el hecho de que puedes jugar con dos arriba pero con un carril abierto que puede ser un atacante,
no sé, digamos que sí que el paso atrás de Arda Guler, creo que puede haber hueco por eso.
De los creadores Miguel de Nacho siempre cumple, llega Gonzalo siempre a porta.
Me gusta, me gusta. Por cierto, dos cositas sobre cosas que se han dicho de Gonzalo.
Davide Ancelotti también dijo que seguramente con ellos también hubiesen jugado en el Mundial de Clubes,
permitidme que lo dude y oye, no es ni mejor ni peor, pero la forma de proceder de los Ancelotti
era ubicar al siguiente jugador en jerarquía, así que hubiese jugado o Rodrigo o Brahim Díaz.
Esto no es casi ni opinión, es un argumento en base al empirismo.
Me gustó mi zogracia de entrevista de Paco González a Braulio.
Esa, ahí va a ir. Estaba jodido.
Claro, es que lo teníamos, ya lo habíamos visto, ya sabíamos que era un jugador que nos podía apartar.
Es que, Nau, yo dije después del...
Y va al Mundial de Clubes y es que el día que no marca asiste.
Yo dije después del primer partido porque ves los goles de Gonzalo, le conoces de inferiores,
ves el primer impacto, los minutos que ya había tenido con el Real Madrid, que habían sido pocos,
y ves también el déficit de delanteros que hay en la Liga.
Y yo puse un tuit de haber de 13 a 15 secretarías técnicas llamando al representante de Gonzalo García en estos momentos.
Y bueno, que Braulio, director deportivo del noveno equipo de la Liga,
reconozca que estaba interesado en Gonzalo García, me parece que es absolutamente lógico y coherente,
porque si pensamos en Rayo, en Celta, que están en Europa o similares, nos saldría algo parecido.
Acaba de dejar desde llano un clipin para la historia del canal.
¿Qué pasa?
Me he querido sonar los mocos de manera discreta para que no digáis ya están los mocos de Al.
Mira, la cualidad que mejor te define no es la discreción.
No la discreción, no la es.
Por eso he dicho que voy a silenciar el micro, voy a aprovechar que Miguel está con un speech que se está mirando en la cámara,
y no tal que el cabrón de Adri le he visto que está mirando todo el mundo.
Voy a agacharme aquí en la mesa.
Cuidado con estos clipines que a mi hermano Damiano David en Mane Skin en Eurovisión le pasó algo parecido.
Claro, cuidado.
Pero Damiano no estaba grabando a las 11 de la mañana.
Bueno, pero Damiano igual sí que llevaba algún complemento.
Mendismo 23.
Viendo las sorpresas en el lado izquierdo del cuadro, que es básicamente el lado de Palmeiras, Chelsea, Fluminense y Alilal,
¿Veis a alguno de esos tres equipos no europeos llegando y ganando la final?
Teniendo en cuenta que es un torneo a un partido único, nos dice, si es así, ¿vale?
¿Cuál creéis que tiene más opciones?
¿Cuál sería vuestro caballito de batalla ahí después de que perdieramos a Flamengo?
Que de haber estado en ese cuadro creo que lo hubiésemos dicho todos,
porque era el que pintaba junto a, diría yo, Alilal con más empaque.
Yo me quedaría, creo que con Al Gilal, pero me gustaría que fuese Palmeiras.
Yo estoy ahí.
Obviamente creo que Al Gilal tiene...
Por nombres puede tener más, incluso desde el banquillo creo que puede tener más,
pero me parece que Palmeiras sería una opción bastante importante,
sobre todo viendo cómo el Chelsea está planteando este Mundial de clubes en distintas maneras.
O sea, es que el día del Benfica incluso tiene una primera parte de dominio brutal,
pero luego la segunda se termina cayendo, te abre un poco la puerta,
el tema del aplazamiento le permite al Benfica empatar.
Pero tú crees que es un planteamiento y no que el Chelsea es una castaña pilonga.
Sí, partiendo de lo que...
Claro, claro.
Pero me refiero a partiendo de la base, de que tienes a Neto, que está volando.
No sé, tienes un equipo que tiene muchas cosas,
pero que creo que no es tanto un planteamiento de juegos,
sino un planteamiento un poco de Mundial de clubes,
que está yendo por el momento un poco de puntillas,
que está yendo un poco de aquella manera,
intentando ser un equipo que pueda gestionar las cargas, por ejemplo,
pero que yo creo que Palmeiras le puede meter mano.
A mí me gustaría ir fuera de Gilal por acertar algo de los pronósticos.
Bueno, yo creo que los pronósticos aquí caemos todos.
Es un buen propósito.
Ya sabes que voy mucho con Fluminense,
que la boda que tengo en Río es una boda muy de Fluminense,
pero por el otro lado, Gilal,
claro, me permitiría sacar el aprobado, ¿no?
Hombre, yo creo que lo más bonito, creo que estamos todos de acuerdo,
sería Palmeiras o Fluminense,
porque al final, a Gilal...
Lo que estaría guapísimo sería que Estebao,
que tampoco ha hecho un gran mundial hasta ahora,
decidiera meterle cinco goles al Chelsea.
Bueno, brutal.
Ahí sí que se va al Estrasburgo de cabeza.
Por cierto, el tema de Gilal me hizo mucha gracia.
¿Visteis el vídeo del presidente de Gilal llorando?
Sí, no.
Y me encanta porque uno ponía como...
Esto es el fútbol.
Un tío que se ha criado ahí alrededor de toda la riqueza más absoluta,
que llora porque su equipo ha eliminado al City en este mundial.
Es verdad que luego nos puede parecer mejor y peor el origen,
la construcción del club y demás,
pero hay una cosa que tiene el fútbol que es eso.
De hecho, se decía que al final,
una cosa bonita que tenía el fútbol,
que creo que ha ido desapareciendo un poquito,
es que democratizaba todo mucho, ¿no?
Porque en la grada te podías abrazar con alguien de un pensamiento contrario,
de una clase social contraria, bla, bla, bla,
y que al final, en la victoria y en la derrota,
todos somos parecidos en ese sentido.
Lo que es brutal es la que se ha liado en el Inter
a raíz de la eliminación ante la Gilal de Simon Inchague.
Ojalá...
Ante flujo, ante flujo.
Ojalá hubiese decidido tirar la cerilla definitiva.
A ver.
¿Qué se está liando aquí ahora en el Inter?
Pues...
Pintaba más la cosa.
O sea, más allá del jihijaja con el tema de Inter...
Ese tramo final...
Yo creo que pintaba más la cosa y cuando ves lo de Chananoglu,
la cerilla de Simone...
Pero aún con todo, el Inter ha quedado mejor que el Reduxasugluvo.
No, no, no abras ese melón.
No, no abras ese melón.
Dije todos los europeos y ni uno ha llegado a cuartos de final.
Me juzga aquí una pena.
El guitarrismo sabe que yo estoy a mis cosas y de repente escucho algo
que me llama la atención y digo...
Hago así como Raven.
Y digo...
Reduxasburgo y el Inter.
El Reduxasburgo quedó el treinta y pico.
Pero evidentemente iba a escala.
Y creo que las realidades que hemos visto es que ningún europeo que estuviese mal
le ha dado la vuelta ni a Letty ni Porto.
Yo creo que la Juve...
Me pareció muy extraño el partido de la Juve contra el Madrid.
Le doy mérito al Madrid.
La picadita de Randall.
Es claro.
El Mundial de Clubes está siendo de un duro para Nahuel Miranda.
Oye, pero es que la jugada es preciosa, que la deja de tacón y todo.
La jugada es preciosa por Gildiz, cabrón.
Que le deja...
O sea, le mete un pase a Gildiz.
La dejadita de Randall que quieres que haga.
¿Qué os caga, chico?
Creo que hizo un buen partido Randall Colomuany.
Más allá del fallo.
Era Mundial de Clubes, Randall.
Yo creo que por ahí, no porque en ese mano a mano, dijo...
Si la tiro por abajo me va a hacer la del divu.
Si llega a meter la picadita, bueno, bueno.
Se la parece ahí.
Realmente cuando vi a Randall Colomuany encarando a Courtois,
se me hizo más largo que lo de Robben y Casillas
y estaba pensando en la chapa de Nahuel.
Yo diciendo por favor, por favor, no.
También te digo que el capullo se quiso pasar
el juego de leyenda.
Sí, sí, sí.
Pero es parte del encanto de Randall Colomuany.
Exactamente. Eso es.
Randall Colomuany no es un 9.
Es un estilo de vida.
Bueno.
Vamos a ver.
Creo que es bastante probable.
Me jugaría...
No sé si una cena, pero sí un postre.
Creo que el Chelsea no llega a la final.
Pero sí que creo que el que pasa por ese lado del cuadro
no gana.
Así que me parece que hay mucha chicha en el otro lado.
Veremos en todo caso.
Jm27.
Haaland es al mismo tiempo un jugador tremendamente efectivo.
Siempre ha roto sus goles esperados,
salvo el año pasado, por cierto.
Y a su vez, también es un tipo que parece que nunca te salva del todo.
¿Qué destino le pronostican al androide?
Me parece una gran pregunta, Adri.
Y un gran debate.
Porque...
Haaland es un poco eso.
O al menos estoy viendo...
O sea, pillas a Haaland en partidos clave de Champions, partidos grandes, demás.
Por supuesto que te condiciona.
O sea, los defensas contrarios empiezan a partir de ahí.
Y eso le da espacio a los otros.
Eso es lo que define a los grandes cracks del mundo.
Que te condicionan con su simple presencia.
Pero coñe.
A mí me lo dicen hace cuatro años.
Y esperaba más imágenes potentes, más eliminatorias y partidos decididos por parte de Haaland.
De los que está teniendo, honestamente.
A ver, es un súper goleador.
No descubro nada. No veo a marcar goles toda la vida.
Porque lo lleva dentro y goles va a seguir marcando.
Pero creo que a estas alturas,
tengo bastante claro que no vamos a ver
la mejor versión de Haaland en el City de Guardiola.
Creo que si Guardiola no ha sacado ya la mejor versión del Noruego,
no lo va a hacer ahora.
Me sigue diciendo que no va a hacer ahora.
Y creo que no va a hacer ahora.
No lo va a hacer ahora.
Me sigue pareciendo un podulista con un difícil encaje
en el ataque tan posicional del Manchester City.
Y ¿dónde lo veo?
El Manchester City.
Firmó una renovación larguísima, cobrando una pasta.
Y no sé si se va a mover de ahí.
Porque si se marcha el City te dirá un pastón.
Que no sé quién podrá pagar.
Sí, yo creo que el tener a Haaland mucho tiempo espaldas a portería.
Al final termina siendo contraproducente.
Yo creo que para el propio jugador y para el equipo.
Para el equipo porque ese apoyo que encuentra el delantero
no es tan fino como probablemente lo pueda necesitar la acción.
Y luego para el propio futbolista que yo creo que está
ciertamente incómodo en diversos momentos.
¿Crees Alex que está estancado precisamente por eso?
Yo tengo la sospecha.
Esto lo hemos hablado más de una vez.
Que quizás el equipo,
o sea Haaland le daba mucho al City.
Pero había que ver cuánto le daba al City a Haaland.
Porque parece muy sencillo.
No, bueno, pues es que le va a poner 27.000 veces en el área.
Ya.
Pero para la evolución del jugador,
para mí Haaland está como super simplificado.
En el Dortmund el último año empieza a tocar mucho de espaldas,
a administrarse mejor, a relacionarse mejor.
Y claro, en un contexto más de transiciones y espacios.
Pero ahora no.
Ahora mismo es ese futbolista que espera que lleguen a línea de fondo
para encontrar su gol como el que marcó el otro día ante Alílal.
Para mí el que puede desactivar esa monotonía de Haaland
es el que tiene que ser el que tiene que ser.
Y es el que tiene que ser el que tiene que ser.
El que desactivar esa monotonía de Haaland es Cherki,
que sea como el de Bruin de la primera temporada de Haaland.
Que sea como el de Bruin de la primera temporada de Haaland.
O sea que le permita dar esos pasos hacia adelante,
o sea que le permita dar esos pasos hacia adelante,
que le permita tener la portería de cara con el balón,
que pueda rematar de primeras.
No sé, para mí es lo único que se me ocurre,
porque sí que veo, sobre todo y creo que en este mundial de clubes
yo creo que ha sido muy exagerado un Haaland,
bueno, demasiado acosertado.
Bueno, demasiado acosertado.
El tema es, yo creo que tiene un tiempo esta parte de la pereza,
y creo que eso acaba contagiando a Haaland,
pensando en el futuro,
como bien decís, a nivel contractual,
parece complicado verle fuera.
Ahora, si le vieramos fuera,
hay dos destinos.
Uno es, uno de los destinos,
uno de los clubes que más dio la murga con Haaland,
te imaginas,
seis meses con cada uno,
del intermedio con Fenix.
A lo día, Estefano.
No, pero uno de los clubes que más dio la murga con Haaland,
al final, es el club de la que más le ha dado la murga,
es el club de la que más le ha dado la murga,
uno de los clubes que más dio la murga con Haaland,
al final, no se la jugó,
fue el equipo de Marlenders,
el Piemonte Calcio.
Sí, es verdad, es verdad.
Y luego,
yo creo que todos los caminos
acaban llevando al Baer de Múnich.
Sí, señor.
Es ese equipo que necesita un golpe
encima de la mesa,
que lleva mucho tiempo sin ilusionarse,
que ha sufrido a Haaland
relativamente, porque tampoco le ha quitado
ninguna liga ni demás.
Yo creo que
serían las dos opciones para
revivir un poco la carrera de Haaland,
pero como decís, parece complicado en el corto plazo pensar en una carrera.
Sí, de hecho,
no es información
porque, pero que sepáis,
que en el,
se lo digo a los pizarritas, que en el
entorno Real Madrid, se sigue
hablando mucho de Haaland.
De hecho, a mí me contaron hace bien poco
que su padre estuvo en Valdebebas.
¿Qué puede parar eso? Ni pa' joder
la idea, porque no, a mí
yo pregunte y digo, bueno, esto es
que Vinicius, ¿no?
Y me decían que no.
O que su padre estaba también alucinando con el iPad
de Xavi Alonso.
O estaba conociendo el circuito, ¿no?
de Fórmula 1 aproximadamente.
El marín. Por aquí va a pasar.
Pueden ser muchas cosas, pero yo sí que creo
que Haaland no cumple el contrato con el City
y que además sería bonito que no lo
cumpliera por aquello de verle
en diferentes escenarios.
A ver, también es cierto, o sea, me parece
más probable que
guardió la seballa del City antes que
Haaland, por ejemplo. Y que ahí veamos
un poco diferente. También es cierto.
Oye, también
molaría pensar
que podría hacer flick con él.
Estaba pensando exactamente en lo mismo,
porque al final otro, o sea, el que más
obsesionado ha estado quizás,
o al menos eso es lo que ha transmitido el entorno
prensa, ha sido La Porta.
Pero esa obsesión de La Porta
también es verdad que
ha sido en la era pre-Lamin, digamos.
Sí, sí. O sea, con
Lamin renovado y tal,
ya tiene la gran figura que decir, oye, el camlo
nuevo, mirad, aquí lo tenéis al chico.
Sí, sí, sí. Pero
veremos.
Pero molaría, eh. Estoy totalmente de acuerdo
en el Barça molaría.
Mortadelo quien bajo RM
dice cortita y al pie. Es momento
Nahuel para que te exhibas,
vale, para que le des la vuelta.
Sin rodeos.
Que cada uno resuelva el cuadro final del mundial
de clubes. Quienes pasan a semis, quienes
juegan la final y campeón.
Comienza Nahuel
Miranda
de armas.
Parera García.
Estaba buscando iconos de Uruguay,
pero bueno.
Adam Barri Suárez.
Cortita, al pie,
sí, cortita al pie, es un poco
paliquera la pregunta, pero mira.
Voy a decir
Gilal Palmeiras,
París, Real Madrid,
y luego yo creo que llega
Gilal a la final.
Y
creo que va a ser
Gilal Paris Saint-Germain.
¿Quién gana?
Ojalá Gilal.
Increíble.
Si gana
los audíces, Nahuel le da la vuelta
a todo el mundo.
Claro, ya ha puesto su
agarra la vuelta, pues que gane Gilal.
Vale, Adri.
Mismas semis que
Nau y en la final
Gilal Real Madrid gana Real Madrid.
Vale. Es el pronóstico que di en
Pizarra. ¿Lo diste?
Sí, dije Real Madrid campeón. Ah, vale, Madrid.
Creía que decías
Alílal Madrid. Digo, coño.
Es un campeón a Gilal.
Yo di Madrid-París-Saint-Germain
porque no vi bien el cuadro.
Sería tremendo si las semis son
Gilal-Chelsea.
Acordaos que Clearway
o la empresa
de Boli.
Bluco.
Correcto.
Mando a casi todos los descartes a
Gilal. Algunos ellos haciendo un torneo
que en su momento estuvo
Eduard Mendy.
Coulibaly está haciendo un torneo tremendo.
Hay un tercer futbolista que me estoy
olvidando que también fue para allá.
Atacante.
Sí.
Que no fue Zidje. Ahora te lo busco.
Alguno por el estilo. Sería bastante
poético que Gilal gane
ese duelo directo. A mí por cierto, quien
me está encantando es Milinko
Visavice. Sé que es un jugador muy
de torneos realmente. Este es otro
de clubes porque con la selección.
Bueno, pero en la selección de
home es que no me acuerdo del torneo. El mundial 2018
yo creo que es. Puede ser, puede ser.
Puede ser que tenga ese recuerdo, pero que es como de
rendimientos cortos, pero
joder. Le convencerá
Belko Pounovic para sumarse
al Real Oviedo después de
aquella gran experiencia hace diez años
en Nueva Zelanda en aquel mundial sub 20.
O para
salvar a Lleida, ¿no?
Que vengan los hermanos Vinco y Saïd
y eso nacidos allí, ¿no?
No parece probable, la verdad. No parece, no te parece.
El cambio
para lo bien, sí, ¿no?
Ehh...
A ver, alguien
tiene que ponerle
balones a Salomon Rondón.
Milinko Visavice que debe cobrar, no sé,
24 camellos, 50.000
porches al mes y
tal. Cuidado que va a decir el límite esa
área de alta. Los camellos son caros.
Claro, por el contrato de cachorla,
seguramente pueda hinchar.
Cachorla.
Jajaja.
Por cierto, Eduard
Bendifue a Al-Aragli, al que era de
Gabriel hasta hace un rato. Es que creo que
Chelsea, a donde lo manda también, es a Qatar,
¿puede ser? Es que hace una...
No, es el PSF. Es el PSF.
A Draxley y a Berratti.
Claro, sí, claro. A
D'Alo también.
No, sí, esa fue preciosa.
Alex ¿cómo queda? Yo
voy a decir qué pasa al Chelsea, para ver si
Agogafé y algún su americano llegan a la final.
O sea, qué pasa al Chelsea, tanto semifinales
como final. La semifinal la jugaría
ante al Hilal y luego
voy a decir
Paris Saint-Germain en la final. Chelsea PSG
y gana
Lucho. Vale, yo digo que
pasa Palmeiras, elimina
al Chelsea, Al Hilal, PSG
Madrid y
la final es
Palmeiras
PSG y gana el Paris Saint-Germain
de Vichy.
Así que ahí queda,
tu pregunta respondida.
Yo te digo una cosa.
Si Palmeiras llega a la final
contra PSG... No La Palma.
No, vale. No, no.
¿Pronóstico de tarjetas amarillas
en el partido?
¿Tiempo efectivo del partido? A ver.
Después... A ver, te quiero decir. Creo que aquí
quien se llamaba La Palma era Botafogo.
Sí, no, no, pero...
Es un escándalo. O sea, el Palmeiras
Botafogo. O sea...
Por favor, eh. O sea...
Yo lo disfruté una barbaridad, pero...
Pero porque no tenía a ningún
familiar sobre el terreno del juego.
Se nota que hace tiempo que no es Copa Libertadores.
No, coño. Si...
Si evidentemente siempre es Libertadores así, ya lo sé,
pero que... coño, si
además lo puse en Twitter, que se agradecía que hubiese
Libertadores a esa hora de la tarde, ¿no? Porque
se vivía de forma un poquito más
intensa que cuando estás por la noche derrotado.
Emilio Cabrera. Si se da esa final,
¿cómo va a anular Gustavo Gómez
a Dempele?
No, no. Y yo te diría
Richard Ríos sobre Vitinha, ¿eh?
Bueno. Veremos. Richard Ríos con Vitinha
a lo pronto se dice a Quintana, aquí lo tienes.
Termina
como el de Los Simpson, ¿eh? El del
fútbol americano que se le va la pierna a la pierna.
Este es tuyo. Emilio Cabrera
pregunta por un Atlético de Madrid, que hubiese estado
en ese lado más amable
del cuadro. Luego, es verdad que también
leo, digo, a ver, tenía que haber eliminado el Atlético de Madrid
a Palmeiras, ¿eh? Que esa sería otra, pero bueno.
Pregunta Emilio, ya
hablamos de mercado de fichaje, chicos,
¿el Atlético debe fichar para que
Julián sea el nuevo titular
o segunda punta? Este es un debate que
hay ahora abierto con esto, bueno,
publicaba nuestro compañero Medina hace
bien poquito que se iba a hacer una inversión
récord, además inversión neta,
¿vale? No de gasto, menos
ingresos, bla bla bla, que eso es un poco trampa
a veces. Y claro,
se podía pensar en si puede haber algún
refuerzo para el ataque,
incluso se habla mucho de la figura del regateador
que no te cabe en el Atlético de
Madrid, salvo que Baena pase
a la media punta como acabó jugando en el Villarreal.
Los últimos partidos de Baena en el Villarreal
fueron en la media punta con Jeremy Pinot en izquierda.
Entonces, esto al
final depende un poco de cómo
se ve a Julián Álvarez, si como
el jugador más adelantado
o si como el
segunda punta, el Griezmann. ¿Cómo
lo veis vosotros chicos de cara a,
insisto, la planificación, no ya
de este verano, sino incluso de los siguientes?
A ver, en el
best case escenario diría que ficharon
nueve para que Julián sea el segundo punta
del Atlético de
Madrid, que es donde creo
mejor partido se le puede sacar a
Julián, pero claro, ficharon
nueve para el Atlético de Madrid, ya hemos
visto que es una pasta.
Pagaste bastante dinero por
short-load el verano pasado
y parece que no te vale como
titular, que va a seguir siendo un recurso, así que
me parece difícil,
creo que Atlético de Madrid pueda acceder
a un gran nueve que sea titular.
Y por eso no es más fácil
Adri fichar a un regateador,
pasar a Baena, al enganche
y jugar con Julián
como jugador más adelantado.
Yo sí, yo lo veo así.
Bueno, pero no es la pregunta que
están haciendo, ¿no?
Yo creo que
o nueve o un segundo punta.
No, ya, ya, pero te quiero decir,
pero lo plantea
el Atlético de fichar para que Julián
sea el nueve titular o segunda punta, no te dice
que fiche un nueve o un segundo punta,
sino ¿cómo ves a Julián
para luego fichar? No sé si me explico.
Vale, vale, entiendo.
A ver, yo teniendo el recurso
short-load disponible en el banquillo
y viendo cómo está el mercado
el nuevo, es decir,
porque Samu, bueno, lo vendiste
tú, lo traspasaste tú.
El tema de yo que eres, yo creo
es demasiado dinero para lo que te puede
dar el futbolista y creo que
los otros ya se pueden ir de madre, ¿no?
En cuanto a precio, entonces, entendiendo
que no va a haber un futbolista
a la altura o al nivel que tú pretendas que sea ese
nueve, porque entiendes que tiene que estar
a la altura de Julián Álvarez,
para mí yo iría por el regateador.
Es verdad que si tú vas a buscar ahora mismo
el regateador vas a decir, ostras.
Se estaba publicando, ven seguir.
Ven seguir, sí.
A ver, yo lo podría
encargar, ¿eh? Es ese perfil
puramente regateador, banda izquierda,
para pasar la vaina a la media punta
y dejar a Julián en derecha. Hay que ver
luego el mes de octubre, el mes de noviembre,
el mes de diciembre dónde está el regateador.
También.
Realmente el
futbolista. El futbolista en la banda.
Bueno, vale, pero igual parte
poco más atrás.
Bueno, pero si te pones a pensar
en lo ideal,
hombre, Luis Díaz sería
una solución
a todos sus problemas, querido Alético de Madrid.
Pero hablábamos otro día en el
programa con Medina
y nos decía que un poco el fichaje
del cuarto delantero
o ese perfil de la banda izquierda
si queremos jugar un poquito más a fantasear
va a ser el último fichaje.
Por tanto, el fichaje que
se va a llevar a la economía más pequeña.
Entonces, yo creo
que va en la izquierda,
solo si Julián arriba y
el cuarto delantero, pues un perfil
pues muy
pensando. Yo le planteaba a Medina
el perfil cuña en su día.
Algo así.
Un futbolista que
pueda crecer dentro del equipo, que no tenga
aspiración de ser titular de manera inmediata
y que veremos si puede resolverle
cosas al equipo de Madrid. ¿Quién fue el brasileño
que sonó? ¿Cómo se llama?
Fue el máximo goleador brasileira el año pasado.
Si no lo sabes tú, hermano.
Ah, Jopé.
Es que se me ha olvidado. Me lo pasó
Barrios el otro día. No, Barrios te pasa
demasiadas cosas. Sí, la verdad que sí.
Demasiadas.
A ver, te lo busco. Sonó para el
Barrios. Navigol, ¿te imaginas?
Vito Góquez.
Alexandro. No.
Joder. Eh...
Rivaldo.
Se llama Vito...
Jury Alberto.
Es el juazo.
Fue el máximo goleador de...
Ah, Jury Alberto. Vale.
Jury. Había entendido Jury Alberto.
Jury está un poco mayor ya.
Pero Jury.
El segundo máximo goleador del
brasileirao el año pasado fue
Ale Random. Que era este...
Sí, mítico. Ale Random.
El que sonaba para el Sevilla.
¿Jury Alberto estuvo en el Zenit?
Sí, sí. Sí, claro.
Internacional de Porto Alegre.
Lo fichó Corinthians dentro de una
operación que hicieron un poco de
oye, vamos a traer talento
de nuevo, ¿no? Trajeron a William, a
Roger Guedes, a Jury Alberto.
Y el tema de Jury Alberto, a ver,
a mí me parece un perfil
muy para ser Correa, ¿no?
Es verdad que es diferente a Correa.
No es un foalista tan... Sí, pero
es el rol. Es el rol.
Sí, lo único que creo es un poco más estrella
y creo que es un foalista un poco más
fuera de los terrenos
del juego con...
Hay que ponerle un poco como en los bolos,
¿sabes? Que ponen los raíles.
Para los adioses. Que no se salga la bola, ¿no?
Pues un poquito, sí. Para que no se salga la bola.
A ver, también es verdad que por lo que nos decía Medina el otro día
que decía Anau en el programa,
ya que va a ser la última inversión
y sabiendo que a Letiuc de Madrid trabaja...
Le gusta trabajar
el mercado de las agentes libres,
no descartaría que ese último foalista en llegar
sea un Menfil de Paille de la vida.
Luka Jovic.
Para la plantilla.
Un Perfila.
Me estaría solo, ¿eh?
La cual que hacer está libre. En esa posición
no me ilusionaría demasiado,
pero insisto, a mí lo de Julián
como un futbolista más adelantado
ya me gustaba el año pasado y creo
que puede serlo. O sea...
Oye, pero fuera de bromas,
como... No tienes un duro,
¿no? Porque ya te vas a haber gastado el dinero
en... Bueno, Johnny Cardoso,
Baena, Ruyet...
El tema de central veremos si es el Cuti
Romero o no.
Intentar apurar las últimas horas del mercado
y cazar al típico 9...
Bueno, como pasó con Ocimé en la
temporada pasada, que el Napoles no lo consigue sacar
y el final acaba en...
Y no crees que esa oportunidad
podría ser un Darwin Núñez pagando
un coste de cesión alto con algún tipo
de opción de compra. Es que yo lo de Darwin
creo que se va a resolver antes.
No, no...
No conozco la negociación,
no tengo información, pero es que ves
noticias todos los días. Me da la sensación de...
Napoles, sí. Sí, el Napoles
lo van a apañar antes de agosto.
Creo, eh. Veremos.
Dusan Blaubits. Una gran relación
con Ruyeri. Muy buena.
Muy buena. A mí Blaubits
me empieza a dar una pereza
prácticamente... Joao
Felicesca, eh. También da pereza
Moise Ken y le va a dejar bastante pastel a Fiori,
eh. Parece que se va a Arabia. No, no, y
Moise Ken ha hecho un temporada
curioso, eh.
Digo Moise Ken porque lo tuvo hecho
Atlético Madrid. Estuvo en el
Metropolitano. Estuvo en el Metropolitano.
Es una de esas operaciones tremendas.
Señor Papo91 pregunta por
un fútbolista que parece que va a dejar a Atlético Madrid,
además dejando una buena
cantidad de dinero. Me sorprende un poquito...
Mira que soy de Rodrigo Riquelme, pero me sorprende un poquito
el valor que se le ha dado.
¿Os parece a Rodrigo Riquelme el tipo de
equipo que va a ser el mejor para sustituir a Jesús Rodríguez?
Y dice, contando con que el lateral
izquierdo va a llegar prácticamente seguro Junior Firpo,
parece que está atado.
Este puede entenderse bien con Riquelme
al meterse Rorro más para dentro y dejar la banda
libre para Junior.
A mí Rorro en el Betis me encantaría.
El Betis le lleva siguiendo desde hace tiempo.
Me parece que encaja a la perfección.
Me parece que es el tipo de equipo a nivel
de exigencia,
posibilidades,
libertad perfecto para Rorro.
Sí, me parece perfecto.
Creo que la única duda es
cómo él...
No va a ser...
No es llamar ratón al Betis, pero que se me entienda.
No va a ser cabeza de ratón porque ya esa cabeza
es hisco al arcón y me gustaría ver
cómo puede ser esa teórica bicefalia
porque Rorro es un fotodista que recibe en zonas
parecidas y que toma muchas decisiones,
pero creo honestamente que es un fichajón
para el equipo y sobre todo
de proyecto. Lo que me parece
un pelo sobrepagado,
toda la situación de Rorro en el Atlético de Madrid.
18 finalmente.
Se hablaba de...
Sí, el 50%...
Eso es 9.
Sí, 9 por el 50%.
Pero valorar a Rorro en 20 millones
me parece como una tasación más
Premier que Liga Española.
Insisto que me gusta mucho.
El Villarreal no la compró esa valoración.
Bueno, es que
a Moleiro le ha costado menos.
Y yo no tengo claro si me quedo con Moleiro o Rorro
en el futuro. No lo tengo claro.
Pero por la situación de Rorro en el Atlético de Madrid
y la necesidad de salida,
si el Atlético sigue 15
ya va sobrado y si consigue 18
pues es una buena venta.
A mí me parece que es una operación
que me hubiera encajado más
enfocarla como una cesión
con probable opción de compra
que no directamente con una compra.
Y ahora mismo Rorro
en nuestra cabeza vive
el recuerdo de lo que fue el fútbolista del Girona.
Porque en el Atlético de Madrid
no ha terminado ni de tener continuidad
ni de ganársela.
Entonces bueno, ahora obviamente tenemos la duda
de qué tipo de fútbolista puede ser.
Obviamente de lo que tenemos en Girona
encaja una barbaridad dentro del Betis.
Pero ha pasado tanto tiempo
esa cabeza ha cambiado
que puede ser diferente.
Aún así, yo lo veo
con un encaje muy positivo dentro del Betis.
Será el momento para que él
pueda aprovechar esta oportunidad.
Y yo imagino que él también lo verá así.
Un equipo que va a jugar el año que viene
en competición europea, que ha hecho
una temporada como la que ha hecho este año,
apuesta por ti de esa manera para esa banda izquierda,
pues creo que es una magnífica operación
para todas las partes.
A mí también me encaja mucho.
Creo que el perfil
me parece muy interesante.
Porque es menos extremo que Jesús Rodríguez,
pero es que en ese extremo ya tienes a Abde.
Y si hubieses querido pichar un extremo extremo,
pues tenías la opción de Brian Zaragoza,
que es el mejor jugador de las partidas
para el Betis este verano.
Así que me gusta mucho, me encaja y creo que
además a Riquel me va a venir bien el cambio de aire.
Y tienes a Pablo García,
que también es un perfil muy extremo,
que es lo que viene por detrás.
A mí me parece
una buena venta del Betis, sinceramente.
Que además conserva un porcentaje.
La de Jesús.
Y luego a la hora de sustituirle,
viendo que
vas a tener bajas en el centro del campo,
que Fornal está jugando cada vez más en la base.
Ese perfil de media punta
echada a la banda, creo que
Peleirín siempre lo agradece mucho y lo puede
ejercer muy, Riquelme.
Con lo de Jesús, esto ya lo comenté
en su día cuando hicimos el análisis del Betis,
que hubo muchos pizarritas véticos.
Bueno, lo de siempre no, que a veces
nos ven como prensa nacional que no nos enteramos
de mi sala media. Bueno,
ahí tenéis las cifras de la operación Johnny Cardoso
y ahí tenéis lo de Jesús Rodríguez. A mí lo que
me cuentan es que el club veía
con buenos ojos vender a Jesús por la cantidad
de la que se viene hablando,
porque básicamente creen que es lo
máximo que van a poder sacar.
No sé si eso significa que no se fían del todo,
que no le van a poder dar más escaparate.
No lo sé.
Esto es lo que me transmiten.
A su vez, no sé
si se contará en algún momento,
pero se hablaba de
cierta
falta de sintonía en el vestuario con la figura
de Jesús. Y a partir de
ahí se puede entender un poquito
la operación, que a muchos véticos les ha sabido
mal,
pero que a mí no me parece
una mala cifra.
No me parece una mala cifra.
Es una de las cinco ventas más caras de la historia del vétil.
Es cierto que, por ejemplo, estaba por medio
la de Joaquín, que son 25 kilos, pero es
hace 20 años,
que ha cambiado mucho el mercado y demás, pero
es una cantidad importante.
Y además hay que proteger a Pablo García,
que parece de los especiales de verdad.
Y creo que hay que hacer...
A mí Jesús me lo parece.
Sí, sí, sí.
Pero es que, o sea,
Jesús me parece buenísimo, pero
me parece de lo más especial que ha sacado el
fútbol español en muchísimo tiempo.
O sea, me parece un jugador que no...
Coño, venimos de sacar a la minha mal.
En términos de especial,
se lleva la palma.
Pero quiero decir que, de ver a un chico así,
desde Isco,
no veo a un jugador... Y fíjate que es un
chico diferente, pero, no sé, con un
toque, un carácter, una persona,
un hambre por el gol, que me parece espectacular.
Y además iba a decir que yo
este año
haría hueco a cierto regreso
vético, porque me parece que puede
ser el año. Creo que puede
darse. Raor Patmo.
Sí, sí, sí. Yo creo que puede darse.
Me encajan las piezas
y me encaja.
Hombre, con el descenso del Lyon,
lo de Pola Koku está cantado, ¿no?
No, al final es un gran regreso,
es el que todo el mundo quería y, evidentemente,
yo no quería desvelar el nombre propio
por darle un poco de emoción,
pero bueno, ya ha llegado a Les Dejano a...
Ya sabes que no tengo ninguna
virtud que requiera algo de
disimulo.
Raor Val. ¿Qué tipo de centrales
necesita o quiere Corberán?
Porque si hay venta de mosquera, parece
que el Arsenal y de Yarik, parece
que el PSV, y dice, por cierto,
para mí incompreensible, pues es el cacique
de las categorías inferiores de España,
solo te quedan César Tárrega
y Vic Diaca.
¿Cómo lo ves, Nao?
Yo lo de la venta de mosquera lo puedo llegar a entender
si no renueva y parece que no está por la labor,
a pesar de que le han hecho una oferta importante a nivel
salarial. Lo de Yarik
por 10-12...
Ostras,
yo creo que le das un añito en primera
y
con continuidad y te puede valer
el doble y además lo tienes ahí deportivamente.
¿Mario hermoso no? Estaba sonando.
Mario hermoso no se quiere quedar en Roma.
A mí lo que me cuentan es que
ni Mario ni
ni la señora hermoso
quieren quedarse en Roma.
¿Cómo está el teléfono de Miguel Quintana?
Te digo más.
Y en Luca Quintanini.
Andan preguntando...
Es que no sé sueltarla.
Andan preguntando
por si lo del cuti romero
se hace con el atleti,
porque no verían con malos ojos
volver a Madrid.
Nos ha fastidiado.
Es informe periodismo.
Hay que estar atentos al mercado
a ver cómo se desarrolla.
Igual están preguntando lo del cuti romero
porque les interesa ir al Tottenham.
Eres un mal pensado.
Londres quizá le gusta más que Roma.
El tema de dos centrales.
Hemos descartado muy fácil
que Schenck y Chomert
no puedan tener un último baile.
A ver.
Un baile van a tener.
Si algo hacen Schenck y Chomert
es bailar o ser bailados.
Pero pegados no.
Y esto es muy perdido.
El Valencia está siendo
un baile de la gente.
Y es que no es un baile de la gente.
El Valencia está siendo
con este último cambio
que todavía han aterrizado en Valencia.
Pero ya tiene mando en plaza.
No se filtra nada
desde dentro del club.
Me estoy contando la historia
de lo de Pani Roba.
La gente del club se entera
pocos minutos antes del anuncio.
Tengo muchas dudas de ver
qué aspira Fissar el Valencia.
Por lo que le acopla Corberán,
creo que
se quedan Tárrega y Jack Avion
central con buena salida de balón.
Yo creo que Jarek puede ser eso.
Con Jarek hay ciertas dudas acerca del Coco.
Hace una temporada muy negativa
en torno a eso.
Pero si no crees que eso
con posibilidad...
Hay riesgo de que este chaval se le vaya.
Voy a intentar hacer caja y olvidarme.
Yo entiendo que ese es el
razonamiento de Valencia en la operación de Jarek.
Y tengo muchas dudas
de qué central puede encontrar el Valencia
con ese perfil en el mercado
teniendo un presupuesto limitado.
Es cierto.
Es que tal y como está el Valencia es que es difícil
pensar en qué puede hacer en el mercado
de fichajes.
En un buen Valencia, sano y económicamente
con posibilidades.
Me hubiese gustado mucho y me hubiese encajado bastante
el perfil o el futbolista que va a fichar
el Villarreal, Rafa Marín por ejemplo.
Creo que Rafa Marín podría haber sido
una gran incorporación para este Valencia.
Pero tal y como está el Valencia ahora mismo
y sabiendo que tampoco vas a sacar
un pastón por mosquera, que es ahora
de 18 millones de euros,
eso te va a limitar un poco las opciones en el mercado.
Yo creo que habrá que estar atentos al mercado
Premier también.
Lo que pueda tirar tanto Ron Gurley
como el propio Corberán por algún
contacto, alguna posibilidad,
algún futbolista que busque destacar ahí.
La policía también.
Es hablar de Meryton Holdings.
Se activa aquí la darma.
Llevo una semana que yo no sé
qué está pasando en Madrid Centro.
Madrid Centro
respecto a hace 10 años ha cambiado bastante.
Sí, pero se autogestiona.
La policía...
Si tú lo crees, cámara sí.
Yo sinceramente
entendiendo que
el Valencia en la temporada que viene
juegue con cuatro atrás
o con tres,
yo creo que debería...
Claro, es que ese es otro tema.
Debería buscar para mí un central
que le domine el área.
Creo que es lo que necesita ahora si se va
mosquera, si se va Jarek...
Tárrega me parece.
Sí, Tárrega me parece que lo es.
A mí es que de hecho me encajaría más
en una figura un poco más correctora
porque creo que Tárrega mejorado en esto
es un jugador con una movilidad
le cuesta muchas veces arrancar.
No puedes ser tan bueno en el área
tan alto y luego defender
a campo abierto. Entonces vales 70 millones de euros.
Esa es la realidad. Eres Virgil van Dijk.
Pero también depende
de a qué altura defienda el Valencia.
Si el Valencia va a ser replay y contragolpe,
porque con Corberán ha ido cambiando
según el partido. Ha tenido diferentes presiones y tal.
Si se establecise
más atrás, compro lo de Alex.
Se le lleva algo que me parece importante.
Pero sí que es verdad que un puntito
extra de velocidad que creo que le aportaba
Christian Mosquera,
a mí no me sobra. A mí no me sobra porque
hemos visto al Valencia hacer presiones medias altas
que a mí me han gustado mucho, sobre todo
en Mestalla y que si tienes a dos
Tárregas, cuidado.
El perfil,
por ponerle un nombre, se hace algo parecido
a un Santi Bueno, por ejemplo.
Pero claro,
con qué dinero vas a por Santi Bueno.
En el club creo que se confía bastante en Níquer
Córdoba, por cierto, el central
de la generación 2005.
Tiene pinta de que es el típico fichaje
del Mirandés para la temporada que viene.
No lo veo a corto plazo, pero viene
sacando buenos centrales en Valencia.
Me gusta lo de pensar ya en jugadores mirandés.
Centrales que acaban
contrato, que han acabado contrato
este año.
Alcar. Cursumà.
Siguiente.
Victor Lindelof.
Cuidado.
El reir al Lindelof
es cuidado.
Que fueron 50 kilos
en su día de Lindelof, ¿no?
En el Benfica, la irrupción que tuvo,
yo me acuerdo que estábamos en ecos
por aquel entonces y era tocha,
la de Lindelof.
También la de Ferro, ya sabes cómo salió aquello en Valencia.
Hay un movimiento
muy valencia que puede ser Eric Bailey,
¿no?
Así se la devuelven al Villarreal.
Estoy de acuerdo.
Bitzel.
Alex, por favor.
Se trata de que la gente del Valencia
se quede, ¿no?
Te digo una cosa, Bitzel,
en una defensa de tres
en el Valencia,
capitán general.
Bitzel capitán general.
En una defensa de tres.
Vallejo.
A mí lo de Aspilicueta no me sonaría mal.
Lo relacionan con el Celta.
Oye, que poquito se ha hablado
de lo de Saúl, ¿eh?
¿De qué de todo?
Se habla de jetaje.
No, no, no.
El rumor que, vamos,
que me ha etiquetado todo el mundo el Celta
es lo de Vigo. ¿En serio?
Te juro que salió antes de ayer.
¿O ayer o antes de ayer?
¿Me acordáis que en un...
Tengo un fichaje para ti.
No, creo que...
No, no, no. En un tengo un fichaje para ti
yo le di el nombre de un jugador de la Liga
belga, ¿vale?
Que era una paja, como la de Banat con el Girona.
Pues hubo gente en Twitter que dijo
que le había llegado la información
de que el Celta estaba interesado en ese jugador.
Los insiders.
Los insiders a veces
necesariamente se masa dentro.
Y lo de Saúl...
Bueno.
No le...
Lo veo tan poco probable.
Cerrad los ojos, si cree.
Cerrad los ojos.
Alex, estaba pensando... Claro, es que
me he puesto a trastear con típicos
jugadores que no van a jugar muchos sus equipos
en la Premier.
Anselmino, el ex de Boca,
el del Chelsea, le ves jugando en la Liga.
Lo estaba pensando para el Valencia,
pero es el típico fichaje
en Sovarnicea.
Pero Anselmino será en el Porto, ¿no?
No, ya no.
Anselmino.
Claro, claro.
Qué grande, Miguel.
Estoy infravalorado como humorista.
Creo que ya muchos pizarritas
se están comenzando a dar cuenta
porque aquí los bufones...
O sea, claro, hacen cada...
Oye, oye, oye.
Pero los Januigis...
Pero desde...
¿Dónde está el faltamiento?
¿Dónde está?
Pero lo digo desde el punto de vista positivo,
que aquí todas las gracias a Nao y Alex
se les ríen fácil, pero a mí no.
Son años de trabajo.
Ha sido años de trabajo, Miguel.
Como diría...
Sólo uno de nosotros tiene el peinado de bufón.
Pero, Miguel,
como diría Asesino, no es solo la barra,
es quién puede decirla.
Chapó.
KenanP17.
¿Qué opinión
os merece el sorteo semi dirigido
de la liga?
¿Haríais algún cambio para que sea más puro
y que pueda verse un clásico en agosto o diciembre?
Aquí, por un lado, me ha hecho mucha gracia
ver ayer como gente descubría que el sorteo
no era un sorteo como tal, sino que es
tremendamente dirigido por varios condicionantes.
Pero que lleva años así.
O sea, a tope con
estar en contra.
Que había ayer gente llevándose
las manos a la cabeza
con algo que viene pasando ya los últimos años.
Y veías a gente como con
Obillito de Lana juntando...
Las últimas temporadas ha sido esto. Pero es que siempre es así.
A mí
puedo entender ciertas
cuestiones porque para vender los derechos
televisivos necesitas ciertas
cuestiones, sobre todo con el clásico.
Y, oye,
¿nos compensa que el clásico se estime en unas
fechas a cambio de que nos paguen más en derechos
internacionales 50 millones?
Pues ahí es la pregunta que tienen que
responder los clubes. Responden que sí.
Porque la Liga son los clubes.
Vuelvo a lo de siempre.
Lo que sí tengo claro es que me parece
demasiado dirigido.
O sea, puedo entender ciertas cuestiones que te
encompensen. Puedo entender ciertas
cuestiones estructurales. Rollo...
Un equipo que está
reformando el estadio, juega las tres primeras
jornadas fuera de casa. Lo entiendo.
Me parece que la Liga debe tener esos guiños en esos casos.
Pero...
Me parece demasiado.
Me parece excesivo lo dirigido
que está y me gustaría más simétrico
como era antes.
Yo creo que estamos todos de acuerdo.
Creo que da un poco
de pereza saber que los clásicos
se juegan siempre en las mismas fechas.
En general, siempre es octubre el primero,
mes de marzo, abril, como muy tarde
de mayo, el segundo.
Que acá son los dos grandes partidos que hay en la Liga en la
temporada. Hombre, ya puestos,
podríamos hacer como en Argentina,
la jornada del clásico
hacer todos los derbis.
Es que esto es una cosa
que parece que cuando
hacemos algo mal
parece que nos llevamos las manos a cabeza
o somos malísimos todos, pero luego
vemos la NBA y nos flipa que en el día de
Navidad haya un Boston Celtics
Los Angeles Lakers. ¿Por qué se hace?
Primero por tradición, segundo por derechos
televisivos.
El primer también está muy dirigido, por ejemplo.
Para mí es verdad que me parece
excesivo.
Me parece demasiado.
Porque ves patrones
y ves que al final hay muchos
partidos muy parecidos.
No sé.
A mí aquí hay un tema
que sobre todo
lo que me molesta más es lo que se haya quitado la simetría.
A mí me parece que...
A mí eso
no sé por qué, pero me revienta.
Pero me parece que era una manera también
muy lógica que tenía esto en la cabeza
de decir, vale, ahora escojo el rival
de este o me enfrento a este, ¿sabes?
Como que iba recogiendo rivales de otro equipo.
O incluso ese tour mallet que sabías que en la primera
parte de la temporada te tocan, yo qué sé,
me imagino, Madrid-Zalleti y
Fútbol Barcelona en cuatro partidos.
Y sabías que en la segunda vuelta te iba a tocar también
a la inversa. Eso
estaba guay.
A mí me gusta más así, como ahora. Asimétrico.
Sí.
No, no.
Los fans de los simétricos...
Los fans del nuevo formato de la Champions.
Incongruencias.
El que
molaba mucho era el
formato de las eliminatorias en
Sudamérica que hasta hace...
O hasta esta última eliminatoria
era siempre el mismo calendario.
Uruguay empezaba siempre en casa con Bolivia, acababa
en casa con Argentina.
Mami, está.
Última cuestión.
Miguel
R.Madrid
7. Quiero vuestra opinión
sobre las palabras
de Rummenigge. ¿Sabéis cuáles son?
Sí. Sobre...
Bueno, dijo Rummenigge
que los futbolistas no pueden quejarse tanto
del calendario si luego quieren
salarios más altos. Y nos
pregunta si estamos de acuerdo. Es una
cuestión que hemos tratado muchas veces,
pero donde a mí
me gusta siempre alinearme del lado del
Bayern, porque el Bayern en su día
habló, igual fue también Rummenigge,
me encaja, habló de cómo
el hecho de que más jugadores
sacan contrato, haya más
representantes e intermediarios,
saca dinero del circuito del
fútbol. Porque ahora
si el Bayern paga 50
millones por
el futbolista que sea... Voltemade. Por
Voltemade, no recibe
50 millones el equipo
de Voltemade. Lo recibe, igual lo
recibe 40 y recibe 5
el tal, no sé cuánto.
Si un jugador... 30 Alexander Arnold. ¿Cuánto
hubiese pagado el Madrid al Liverpool?
Incluso el último año de contrato. 30, 40
millones de euros. Pues esos 40 millones de euros
no van para el Liverpool. Ahora, es verdad
que no van para el jugador, pero hay
10, 12 que van para el jugador.
Pero ya no es solo eso, vete al fecha de TAC.
Por ejemplo, por ejemplo.
El Bayern no ha visto ni un euro, lo ha visto TAC.
Bueno, claro. También os
digo que no tiene por qué estar relacionado
estrictamente con
la agencia libre.
O puede ser el fichaje de
Haaland por el Manchester City. Yo creo que se paga
mucho en comisiones que traspaso.
A lo que voy es que... Eso lo dijo Rumenigge
hace... Yo creo que igual fue el verano
pasado. Ahora ha dicho esto.
Y refuerzo una cosa.
Que por esto está el Mundial de Clubes y más
historias. El fútbol no produce el dinero
que se está pagando a los futbolistas.
Está máxima de...
No, es que lo generan. Es que es mentira.
Hay muchos clubes
que van a la deriva
económica, que van a
pérdidas. Muchas ligas que van así.
Y bueno, sacamos a cenar el vídeo
del Olympique de Lyon, por ejemplo.
Y luego, para
poder ir pagando a jugadores,
entrenadores y demás,
se van inventando competiciones con más
y más partidos porque las cifras
no dan.
Entonces, yo soy el primero
que rebajaría el calendario,
pero también soy el primero que, si esto
no lo acuerdan los futbolistas
y pierden cierta parte del
pastel, es imposible.
Es que no dan las cifras
que se están pagando. Y esto se lo preguntas
a cualquier dirigente de la liga y te habla
de que es la masa salarial de los futbolistas,
lo que les impide luego reforzarse
de mayor manera en el mercado.
A mí lo que me depende de esta
situación es que
a estas alturas no
haya habido ya una movilización
importante de los
futbolistas si realmente están
todos...
¿Tuvo la amenaza?
Ya, pero que no se haya hecho algo ya.
O sea que no hayan protestado ya.
Lo cual, claro, ellos son los primeros que saben
que a más partidos, más pasta.
Y luego, los grandes
futbolistas que son los que juegan las grandes
competiciones, es que quieren jugar estas grandes competiciones.
Se quieren estar en los grandes torneos, porque saben
que esto va a ser beneficioso para sus carreras
para seguir moviendo la rueda y seguir ganando pasta.
Así que yo creo que si no ha cambiado
ya, tal y como está el calendario,
que ya es difícil meter más competiciones,
veo difícil que vaya a cambiar, al menos a corto plazo.
Tú imagínate, coge...
Son 32 equipos en el mundial de clubes,
¿no?
Pongamos que son 22, 23, 24,
25 las plantillas, ¿vale?
Claro, el número
de futbolistas profesionales
en comparación al global de
futbolistas profesionales que existe en el planeta,
que hay futbolistas que hay en el mundial de clubes,
el número es muy reducido.
Yo ahí me imagino que la
escasa
fuerza que pueda tener
un grupo reducido de futbolistas respecto
al resto, es lo que les está frenando.
Es verdad que las voces que a priori
se levantarían serían las más potentes,
porque son los mejores equipos.
Fue Rodri. Claro, fue Rodri,
fue Laporte, o sea, hubo
futbolistas que se levantaron,
que pidieron precisamente eso.
Pero claro, luego también,
luego me imagino
si esos futbolistas
se quejan, pongamos que van a la
huelga, pues el Manchester City le dice a Rodri,
vale, no te preocupes,
no vamos a jugar el mundial de clubes,
vamos a hacer todo lo que esté en nuestra mano para que la
Champions dure menos, pero
entiende que en lugar de ganar,
no sé cuánto gana Rodri,
siendo actual balón de oro, pero
imaginemos que gana 20 millones de euros al año,
pongámoslo en esa cita, pues
si gana 20 vas a ganar 12.
Entonces ahora ahí tiene que ver Rodri,
tiene que ver el resto de futbolistas,
si quieren ganar 12 y no jugar el mundial de clubes.
Es que si esa pregunta es la que está sobre la mesa,
también se ha quejado Guardiola del calendario
y dice, de verdad, que me parecen quejas superlícitas,
es que nosotros nos quejamos permanentemente.
Nosotros estaríamos dispuestos
a quizás perder alguna visita
o algo por no haber
mundial de clubes o Champions con menos jornadas.
Nos afectaría levemente
y preferiríamos más espectáculo y mejor
nivel a eso. ¿Está dispuesto
Guardiola a que no tenga 400
millones en Manchester City para reforzarse
en dos ventanas?
Porque estamos hablando un poquito de eso. ¿Está dispuesto
Jurgen Klopp a
cobrar menos de 12 millones
de euros que cobra como director de futbol
de Red Bull? ¿Director de
futbol? Es que
esa es la pregunta que hay sobre la mesa.
Entonces yo estoy de acuerdo con Rummenigge.
Porque el Bayern
es tremendamente
coherente. El Bayern es extremadamente coherente.
Porque a mí hay una cosa.
El Bayern está mamando lo que no está escrito
en el mercado de fichajes. No firman a nadie.
Claro. Pero, Nau,
permíteme elogiar simplemente la coincidencia de
Rummenigge, porque creo que el Bayern es el que más
necesita la Superliga precisamente por todo
esto. Y el Bayern no quiere
por su tradicionalismo, porque no compra
el este y tal. El Bayern puede hablar.
Y el Bayern y Rummenigge
se están quejando, creo que con
razón. Y son de los pocos que no siguen el
juego a esa dinámica.
No les va a quedar otra, Miguel.
No, no, lo van a tener que hacer. Eso está claro.
Los clubes que van a pérdidas, o sea,
que lo hacen para poder competir en mejor
situación. O sea, no lo hacen porque
quieren estar en pérdidas. Claro, claro.
El Bayern,
en Alemania, en general,
a nivel empresarial hay
una forma de hacer las cosas
muy tradicional y es muy difícil
mover eso. Es muy difícil de cambiar.
De hecho, el CWC
en Alemania se intentó hacer para
potenciar toda la parte de
digitalización
de los clubes.
Y en un primer momento hubo una posición radical
y casi que la Liga lo tuvo que aprobar
sin mucho consenso entre
los representantes del fútbol alemán.
Yo, de toda la reflexión que hacía,
con lo único que no estoy aburrido, es que el fútbol
no lo genera. Igual, en general,
como industria siempre hay alguno que pierde.
Pero es que
hay actores que inyectan dinero a pérdidas
sin que les importe demasiado.
Estamos en un mundial de clubes
que está patrocinado por Arabia Saudi
que ha inyectado mil millones de euros y que si en esos
mil millones de euros sería imposible entender
el mundial de clubes y que se vea gratuito
todo el mundo. Pero a lo que te voy
es que, qué decir, porque muchas
veces se utiliza esta frase de el fútbol lo genera.
Esto se decía mucho en el fútbol español
cuando los clubes debían
un dineral ingente a la seguridad
social y hacienda. Es una
realidad. Y ahora eso no sucede tanto.
Y a la que les han apretado
con que esto hay que
pagarlo, si no pierdes puntos, pierdes licencias,
se han acabado las deudas
con hacienda,
con el dinero social y todo esto. Que es lo bueno del límite
salario en la liga, que lo decimos siempre,
que igual ha sido excesivo
en algunos sentidos, pero que en
esto ha venido muy bien. Pero
al final, cuando digo que no lo genera,
si tú necesitas a un país
o a diferentes
jeques para inyectar ese dinero
y que en el circuito del fútbol esté,
como tal no lo genera.
Es que te necesitan ellos a ti, porque
lo que quieren hacer es sport washing y el día que no es Arabia es Qatar
y el día que no es Qatar
igual, claro,
es que, quiero decir, está ahí, está ahí.
Todo el mundo quiere estar metido en el fútbol.
Yo creo que el fútbol lo genera.
Entiendo lo que dices,
que como elemento cultural
o socioeconómico hegemónico,
al final atrae
esa inversión y esa inyección exterior.
Es verdad, pero claro, al final
a lo que te lleva también es a tener que
crear competiciones nuevas,
más partidos y
extremar el elitismo.
Y más lugares a que inviertan ese tipo de asomado.
Claro, claro. Tú no te preocupes que
el día que no se lo puedan...
Tenemos el ejemplo de la pandemia, oye, el momento
en el que se frena la industria
y palmas dinero,
se frena también la inversión
y ya está, y se difieren contratos
y luego
a ver si vuelve la
burbuja a crecer un poco.
Quiero decir, esto se autoregula, es un mercado
yo creo muy abierto y
los que lloran con aquello de que
no lo genera... No, chicos, no lo generas tú
que estás haciendo las cosas mal, no lo genera
el fútbol francés porque la gestión es
terrorífica. Sí, pero hacer las cosas mal
tampoco es el punto porque venderte
a Qatar tampoco es hacer las cosas bien.
Claro. No, no, a
niveles. Estamos hablando a nivel económico, luego a
nivel moral podemos hacer las conversaciones que quieras.
Yo creo que antes de frenar, revienta la burbuja.
Antes de que frene y diga
uy, por aquí no... ¿Cuál es el escenario
que dibujáis de que reviente la burbuja?
Yo lo que creo es que
yo sigo creyendo que habrá algo
parecido a la Superliga,
no digo ni siquiera que lo muevan los actores
que la andan moviendo, pero el concepto,
nos quedamos con el concepto
y creo que habrá un control
económico de salarios,
o sea algo parecido a lo de la NBA, que luego
evidentemente una vez hay más contratos
televisivos y demás,
hay una negociación patronal y se van
subiendo los estándares y demás,
pero sí que me parece que se pondrá algún tope
en ese sentido. Puedo, puedo, puedo dar.
Pero si es que habrá métodos para saltárselos,
es que al final, si tú creas una Superliga,
por ejemplo, no le vas a poner
freno al tema de las multipropiedades,
que es una forma de
saltarse. Claro, todo, todo,
todo, todo, sí, sí, pero por ejemplo,
la NBA tiene el impuesto de lujo, que no deja de ser.
Pero Miguel, la NBA es diferente
porque para empezar
es una liga de franquicias, o sea,
el dueño es uno y se acabó,
entonces yo creo que no es comparable.
El otro día escuchaba
Pepe Brasín con el tema de cómo
han regulado ahora el tema de la agencia libre, que ya pasaba
a ser muy relevante porque le han puesto mucho freno.
Pero es que eso lo puedes hacer
si tú tienes el monopolio de
la liga, y del
basket mundial entre comillas, como es el caso de la NBA.
Si tú, aunque tengas una Superliga,
no le vas a poner freno al tema de las multipropiedades,
vas a poder hacer chanchullos
con clubes que tengas tus
satélites en Portugal, en
Francia, donde tú quieras.
Entonces, ¿le intentas
poder portar esa un campo que no las tiene?
Claro, pero que te voy, es que
todo esto es una deriva tremendamente peligrosa,
tremendamente peligrosa, como analizamos
el otro día con el tema de la Olimpiada de Lyon,
y que en parte
viene de... A mí no me parece peligroso,
quiere decir... Joder,
que haya una serie de grupos
que controlen a clubes
cuyos
ley motifs
sea alimentar al grande, y por tanto
esos aficionados sean
una... puro atrezzo.
A mí me parece que va en contra...
Pero es que va en contra
del fútbol, porque lo que hace
es que, por ejemplo, si
dos equipos, pongamos
un equipo de la Premier, compra un equipo en España,
¿vale? Tiene esa multipropiedad.
El equipo de España, que se está aprovechando,
se está nutriendo a los jugadores...
El Girona, pon el Girona
el ejemplo, ya lo tenemos. El Girona.
El Getafe de Liverpool. El Getafe de Liverpool.
Todo ese tipo de tal. Tú imagínate
que en lugar del Liverpool,
o sea, en lugar del Getafe, compra el Rayo.
¿Te quedas sin Rayo Liverpool?
Porque a ver cómo...
¿Cómo explicas tú?
No, no, pero si lo han apañado.
Sí, sí.
Quiero decir, si hemos visto un partido entre los dos
y el equipo de Red Bull.
Sí, pero con sus trampas.
Pero pregúntale, por ejemplo, ahora...
Que están ahí a la orden del día.
Abuel, esto lo están apretando más
porque este año es el año
que más equipos están expulsando
de las competiciones europeas
por multipropiedad. Claro, no.
Pero es el año que más, hasta el siguiente,
hasta el siguiente. A mí
sí me preocupa de sinercia, en todo caso.
Claro, ¿qué nivel de clubes?
Que yo vi el... Sí, el
de Irlanda y... Claro, claro.
Por saco, eso es claro.
No tiene ningún tipo de influencia política en UEFA.
Pero eso irá creciendo
y luego que los aficionados de esos
clubes, me decen, me decen.
No digo que lo vayan a tener porque como tú dices no tienen influencia.
Pero me decen... Solo por volver al
caso del Fulista, que era lo que antes
quería comentar. Por no seguir con Rodríguez.
Pongámonos en la piel de Mbappé.
Evidentemente Mbappé
no va a hablar con Florentino
y le va a decir Mbappé, si no
en estas competiciones no puedes cobrar 30, vas a cobrar
20. Mbappé le va a decir.
Y la prima de fichaje no va a ser de 200.
De 70.
Sí, lo que sea.
Mbappé lógicamente no le va a decir a Florentino.
Sí, cobro menos dinero y tengo más tiempo de vacaciones.
Esto no va a ser así. Mbappé es el primero que quiere jugar
las grandes competiciones en Mbappé y en Madrid.
Lo que dirán será
igual no quiero jugar 38 jornadas de Liga.
Claro, ese es el punto.
Igual no quiero estar en la
ronda de octavos de Copa del Rey.
Y por ahí van a recortar.
Porque al final lo que dice Al es que
esas nuevas competiciones y esos partidos extras
los juegan unos pocos
que es verdad que a su vez son los que más generan.
Claro.
Y entonces, por eso, a mi me parece que
esto, a ver, que ha pasado en todas las industrias
y en todo,
es algo casi imparable, pero que
cambia mucho el equilibrio del fútbol
y lo va a cambiar tal y como lo conocemos
porque ya lo está cambiando.
El Estatucu está saltando por el fútbol.
El Estatucu está saltando por los aires.
Cierra lo, Al, porque es todo para largo.
Haremos una análisis y una reflexión larga.
Tengo una pequeña pedrada
que igual, no sé, estamos en
2015, ¿no? Pues igual en 2035,
en 2040, este clip-in sale
y dice, ostras, de ya no veo el futuro.
Pero es que tengo un tema en la cabeza
que no me lo saco, ¿vale?
Infantino estuvo
muy en contra en su momento de la Super Liga Europea.
Pero
Infantino fue el que
promocionó,
formó,
insistió en que se hiciera
la Super Liga Africana, que sólo ha tenido
dos ediciones y ya se acabó.
¿Y si
Infantino está tan en
contra de la Super Liga Europea? ¿Por qué
lo que quiere hacer? ¿Es una Super Liga
mundial? Cuidado.
Seguro, seguro. A ver,
Infantino estaba en contra de la Super Liga Europea.
No, no, pero
¿Qué predicción es esta?
No, en el club no está por eso.
Infantino estaba en contra de la Super Liga
porque no la gestionaba Infantino.
Claro. Ahí se acaba
la discusión.
Sobre el cheferín, sobre Infantino
y sobre cualquier persona que se dirigiera al fútbol.
Infantino ha visto que la única competición
que le genera pasta de verdad es el mundial
de selecciones y lo hace cada cuatro años.
Esto lo tengo que hacer dos. Cada dos.
Sí, sí, sí.
Esto es absolutamente así. De hecho,
esto habla de que cuentan que
el cheferín Infantino
comienza
a calentarse.
Porque creo que muchas veces desde Europa
consideramos a la FIFA
como una extensión de la UEFA.
Primero porque ha estado gestionado
por europeos en las últimas décadas
y segundo porque parece que como siempre
van en sintonía, van de la mano.
De hecho, te diría que son de los que menos
poderes tienen la UEFA en FIFA.
Claro, pero es que no es así.
Todos los votos valen igual.
No es así, no funciona de esa manera
y creo que ya empieza
a haber enfrentamiento por esa
tarta del pastel
que parece que la FIFA quiere su trocito
extra y eso es en detrimento
de competiciones UEFA.
O de tronos.
El mundial de clubes
como formato.
Tu predicción es que en 2040
va a haber mundial de clubes, ¿no, Álex?
Va a haber, cuidado,
Superliga Mundial.
Yo le llamaría Super...
¿Cómo has dicho?
Superliga Mundial
que igual es World,
Microsoft,
Petrol,
Super League.
Hasta aquí este
cubano.